hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd
and sunscreen nerd recently you might
have heard that one of my former
favorite sunscreens the purito centella
unscented sunscreen
tested at spf 19 which is much lower
than its labeled protection of spf 50
plus
there were rumors that it didn't match
the label claim before but until
inci decoder published the two in-vivo
spf tests on their blog
everyone was saying that there wasn't
enough evidence yet to disbelieve the
label
this sort of thing has happened with all
sorts of sunscreens from all over the
world before from both big and small
brands
where later testing didn't get the spf
that's claimed on the label
there is the possibility of the newer
test being wrong and the label being
correct
and i'll go into some of the possible
reasons for this later on
but i think most people now feel like
there is enough evidence to be more
cautious
purito put out a statement saying
they've paused the sale of their
sunscreens
and they said that they actually sent
off their sunscreens for a test
earlier but they still haven't gotten
the results yet so were we all wrong to
say the labeled spf was the best data
point we had
should we stop trusting all korean
sunscreens or asian sunscreens
should we only use sunscreens from large
western manufacturers
why did cosmetic formulators and
scientists wait till there were two in
vivo spf tests before saying anything
hopefully this video will give you more
insight into the whole situation and why
spf testing is so darn tricky
if you like nerding out about the
science behind beauty products click the
like the subscribe and the notification
bell so you don't miss any videos
[Music]
let's start with how spf testing is done
i have another video that goes into a
lot more detail about what spf means
and i'd recommend that you watch that
video first in short spf measures how
much protection you get from erythemal
or sunburn causing uv from a sunscreen
or any other product
spf tests are done by putting two
milligrams per square centimeter of
sunscreen on the backs of human
volunteers a special uv lamp is shone
onto the backs
and they compare how much uv the skin
can take with or without the sunscreen
there are a lot of really annoying
things about this test
anything that involves human volunteers
is a lot more expensive than if you just
have to use a machine
it's five to ten thousand us dollars for
a test and if the first version of your
sunscreen doesn't give you a high enough
spf
then you have to repeat this again and
again until you get it and
you are harming people with this test so
the sun care industry has been working
for a long time to find an alternative
way of testing spf
but the main issue that keeps coming up
is that it is really hard to mimic how
sunscreen reacts with human skin
human skin is bumpy and so if you have a
thicker sunscreen then some of it might
not get into the grooves
and you might have little bits of hills
sticking up sunscreens also dry on skin
in a particular way which might be
different from drying on glass or on
different types of plastic
so the international standard test for
spf labeling the iso 24444 test
and the fda test which is very similar
both of these still use in vivo tests on
actual human beings
this applies to most places worldwide
including the us korea and australia
there are little differences between the
regions with things like how
reproducible the test is
and how many volunteers you have to use
but in essence the test is the same
[Music]
so why can't you work out the spf from
the ingredients list
sunscreens are annoyingly complicated
the saying that the ingredients list
can't tell you the whole story about how
a product works
is especially applicable to sunscreens
cosmetic formulators know this really
well
because
sunscreens are one of the
hardest things to formulate
it can take months to finish a sunscreen
one cosmetic chemist told me that she
just finished formulating a sunscreen
and it took her six months
and she started with an spf 30 base and
she just had to raise the spf
so obviously protection isn't just about
the amounts of filters you put into it
because if it was then they'd be done in
a day
this nifty tool is the dsm sunscreen
optimizer
this is a computer model that was
developed by a sunscreen ingredient
company
there's another famous one called the
basf sunscreen simulator
now these tools don't take into account
everything in the final formulation
so if you put in percentages of filters
in here you're not going to get out the
final spf
they can give you an idea of what sorts
of things will change your sunscreen
protection how the absorbance over
different wavelengths will change
but dsm and basf make it very clear that
these are just a starting point for
formulation
if you put in the percentages from a
bunch of real sunscreens
you can see that the spf predicted can
be wildly off
so if these models can't give you an
accurate prediction
then just looking at the filters in a
sunscreen isn't going to be any better
but i am going to use the sunscreen
optimizer to demonstrate a few things
[Music]
first off with the number of filters in
the sunscreen i've heard some people say
that you need more filters for so called
redundancy
that every sunscreen needs to have more
than two filters to give you a high
spf i think this idea comes from the
observation that a lot of the sunscreens
on the market with high spf do have a
lot of different filters
but having multiple filters in there
doesn't mean you actually need to have
multiple filters in there to get a
higher spf
there are a lot of other explanations
for why sunscreens often end up with
multiple filters
firstly if your filters aren't broad
spectrum enough if they're not covering
a wide enough range of wavelengths
then you're going to have to put in
other filters in there to cover the rest
something very broad spectrum like zinc
oxide can be the only filter in a
sunscreen
in the purito sunscreen there are two
filters and some people have said that
these two filters cannot possibly give
you a broad spectrum sunscreen
there's a so-called dip in the uva ii
region because the two filters have
peaks in the uvb and the uva one regions
but this doesn't mean that uva ii isn't
covered enough because both of these
filters do absorb in the uva 2 region
and they can work together in that
region so this is actually one of the
things you can get a decent idea of with
just the ingredients list
it can be confusing if you're not used
to interpreting these sorts of
individual filter spectra
because it does sort of look like
there's a dip there but you are meant to
add them together and the computer model
can do this
so if you put in the percentages into
the computer model assuming these
percentages are correct
you can see there is actually barely a
dip in the uva ii region it is broad
spectrum
these newer filters are excellent the
reason they're not approved in the us
is basically the fda is very slow at
getting these new filters approved
they've recently reopened the case but
they are asking for safety data
based on animal testing and because of
the animal testing ban
the companies can't go and get this
extra specific data
so there's a bit of a stalemate in the
us about approving these filters
until newer non-animal tests are
developed
but based on other safety data they've
been approved pretty much everywhere
else including the eu
and australia sunscreen development is
also really expensive and involves
months of trial and error so say if a
particular brand had an spf 30 formula
they were really happy with
but they see that everyone's moving
towards spf 50 plus products now
they might choose to just add extra
filters to their existing spf 30
sunscreen
instead of trying to start from scratch
again and this process can still take
months and months
but if you add more of the filters you
already had you might exceed the
regulatory limits
or they might solidify out so you get
crystals in the sunscreen formula and it
doesn't work anymore
so adding different filters can get
around this newer filters tend to be
more efficient over a wider
range of wavelengths and so you don't
need as much to get higher protection
and so you don't necessarily hit that
limit i think this is why we see a lot
of sunscreens on the market where they
have some really cool new filters
along with some older filters that
people aren't really that
into anymore like octinoxate and
oxybenzone and
that list doesn't make a lot of sense if
it was actually designed from scratch
there's also the cost of the sunscreen
ingredient if you want to cover the
whole spectrum with one or two filters
and you don't want to go with a mineral
sunscreen then you pretty much have to
use some of the newer broad spectrum
filters
these are more expensive and so even
though it's theoretically possible to
make a sunscreen with just tinosorb s if
you look at the computer model
it would be a lot more attractive to cut
down on that expensive tinosorb
s and chuck in some cheaper filters
instead there are also a few
combinations of filters that work better
together and so combining them means
that you can take advantage of that
[Music]
synergy
so can we tell the spf from the
percentages of the filters
one of the reasons that some people said
purito had to be lying
is that there were low concentrations of
the filters the problem with this is
that yes
the spf does depend on the percentages
of the filters
but also on a lot of other things how
well the formula spreads out the
sunscreen actives in the final sunscreen
film
whether there's spf boosters used again
it takes months and months to develop a
sunscreen formula
so you can get very different final spfs
from the same percentages of active
ingredients and you can't confidently
say that a label is lying or not based
on just those percentages
you can't confidently compare it with
other sunscreens on the market
especially if they're using different
filters there are always new spf
boosting technologies coming out on the
market
and i'm not that knowledgeable about
sunscreens but here are two that i do
know a bit about
sunspheres are a range of transparent
hollow spheres and they can be made of a
lot of different materials
these bounce uv around in the sunscreen
layer so you get a longer path length
and so that means that the uv is more
likely to hit a sunscreen molecule
and get absorbed before it gets to your
skin it basically has the effect of
making the sunscreen layer thicker
hallbrite bhb or butyloctyl salicylate
is a solvent that can increase
photostability and help spread out
filters
the manufacturer has data showing that
swapping this in for another solvent
more than doubled the spf of a zinc
oxide sunscreen
the dsm sunscreen optimizer actually has
a function where you can put in
different solvents
and you can see what effect that has on
the protection but unfortunately this is
currently broken
so these are all inactive ingredients
that can drastically change the spf of a
sunscreen
another related point was that since
larger western international brands
didn't have sunscreens with lighter
textures and lower percentages of
actives
that asian sunscreens had to be lying
the problem with this idea is that
western sunscreen brands haven't really
been aiming for this sort of formula
there just aren't that many sunscreen
nerds in western countries that wear
sunscreen every day
the vast majority of people in western
countries only wear sunscreen when they
go to the beach in summer and their skin
gets really easily burnt
so the average western consumer expects
to go into a supermarket and buy a
sunscreen and not get burnt even if they
don't apply enough
if they don't reapply if they stay out
in the sun for hours and hours and hours
if they brush against sand and towels
and sweat a lot so western brands tend
to formulate for this type of usage and
so their sunscreens often go well beyond
what's claimed on the label
i actually got to talk to some of the
top people in neutrogena's sun r&d
team about their sunscreen development
process neutrogena's helioplex
sunscreens have to keep over 85%
of their uva protection after five hours
of exposure to a midday sun lamp
if it's 84% they just won't release it
they also test the wear of their
sunscreens under all sorts of conditions
including extreme heat and extreme cold
i've been told that some of la
roche-posay sunscreens have well in
excess of their labeled spf protection
the highest allowed in australia is spf
50 plus but they go well beyond this
it's only been in the last few years
that some lighter textured sunscreens
have been released in western markets so
things like neutrogena's hydro boost
and la roche-posay fluid even then the
hydro boost still has that helioplex
label
probably so when a typical western
consumer grabs it and wears it to the
beach
and stays in the sun for hours they
don't sue them because they got burnt
on the other hand in many parts of asia
daily sunscreen wear is very normal
so there's been a lot more effort into
developing sunscreens that are as light
and comfortable as possible
and generally that means cutting down
the amount of filters
but these sunscreens are often designed
for day-to-day use so basically going to
and from the office sitting indoors for
most of the day
a lot of these sunscreens probably wear
off quite quickly if you use them in a
way that's not expected so
on a long sunny walk and i think this is
why some people have been getting burnt
even though they've been applying enough
because it's not really made for that
sort of usage the properties of the
sunscreen film make a big difference
and generally heavier sunscreens don't
move around as much
so if we can't tell what's going on from
just the active ingredients what if we
take the whole formula and test it with
a machine
the problem is human skin you apply
the sunscreen and the sunscreen
interacts with your skin and then your
skin and the sunscreen film go out and
interact with uv
so you still haven't taken into account
the whole equation the way that seems to
work the best
is by making special plates that mimic
human skin and so when the sunscreen
applies it dries on it just like it
would on skin
this sounds really obvious and
straightforward but it's really not
scientists have been working on this for
literally decades and it looks like
there's finally a few methods that might
be good enough to be accepted for spf
labeling
the best method so far seems to be the
cosmetics europe method
very briefly this uses a robotic arm to
spread the sunscreen on two different
specially roughened plates
they take four different uv absorbance
readings and then they put it all into
an equation that calculates the spf
this method is being rolled out and
hopefully will be accepted in the next
few years but right now it still hasn't
gotten that official tick of
approval with other in vitro methods
that use plates there's been a really
big difference between what you see
on the plate and what you see in vivo on
human skin this graph shows the
correlation and the closer the dot is to
that diagonal line
the more accurate it is so you can see
some data points that are really far out
here so for example this one on skin was
35.1
in vitro on the plate it was 12. this
one
on skin was 61.2 but the in vitro
prediction predicted 29.
it also goes the other way so this one
in vivo was 20.3
but all four methods overestimated it at
31.5 to 42.7
so clearly testing in a lab without
human skin can be really inaccurate
what if we test on human skin but with a
simpler method one method i've seen
suggested for checking how much spf you
have is by looking through a uv camera
and seeing how dark it is
i've actually spoken to the maker of one
of the most popular uv cameras the
sunscreenr
and he says that no you cannot tell the
spf from how dark it is
the camera is qualitative and not
quantitative it only tells you where you
spread the sunscreen
and possibly whether it's gotten lighter
or darker with the same sunscreen
but you can't compare between different
sunscreens so the darkness can't tell
you if it's spf 15 or spf 100
part of this is because you can't see
how continuous the film is
microscopically
so it's far too low resolution for that
it's also to do with how these cameras
work
they work by using specific uv
wavelengths not the entire spectrum of
erythemal uv which is how we get spf
so if you have a sunscreen that happens
to be really biased towards that
particular uv wavelength
then it'll be really dark if you have
one that's particularly not biased
towards that wavelength it might be
really light
even though overall they end up working
around the same sunscreens that reflect
or scatter
uv also look a lot lighter even if
they're only reflecting or scattering a
tiny amount it can still look a lot
lighter on that photo
so the main thing you can tell with
these cameras is just if you've missed a
spot while applying which is exactly
what these cameras were designed for
[Music]
so all of these issues with these other
methods is why the in vivo spf test is
still the gold standard this is what's
used for the label so unless you have
evidence that matches up to the in vivo
test that's used for the label
you can't really say very much and we
can see that other tests just don't
really measure up
but there are some issues with this gold
standard even though it is the best
thing we have
the main test used is the iso two four
four four four spf tests so this was
where you get human volunteers and burn
them for science
and like i said there are lots of issues
with this like cost and harm
but there is another really big reason
why we're so desperate to replace this
test with an in vitro spf test
and this is reproducibility in other
words testing the same sunscreen using
this method doesn't necessarily give you
consistent results
the differences between spfs that
different labs get has always been a
really big issue
so for example procter and gamble sent
the same spf 100 sunscreen to five
different labs
they told the labs that the spf was
somewhere between 20 and 100
and they got back five very different
results between 37
and 75. in another test the five labs
were sent another sunscreen and they
were told that it was
spf 80. three labs scored a pretty close
to spf 80.
the two other labs gave at 54 and 70. so
when the labs were told in spf value
they were more likely to get that
expected result and so it looks like
there's some element of bias happening
one thing i did notice in the inci
decoder test was that the lab was told
that the spf would be around 20. i'm
guessing when purito did their test they
told their lab that it would be higher
and so this extra information might have
influenced the results
so all of this variation is why there's
been a revision to the iso 24444 in 2019
some of the things that are now
specified which could give more accurate
spf results include
the sunscreen has to be applied in drops
so at least 15 drops per
30 square centimeters the drops have to
be spread circularly and then up and
down and then side to side
the process of spreading the sunscreen
on the skin has to be 30 to 40 seconds
through the whole process the gloved
finger shouldn't leave the skin the
people who decide if the skin is burnt
or not have to have their colour vision
checked
and it's recommended that they get
rechecked every year instead of having
an expert classify the skin colour
there's a limit on the specific skin
colours of volunteers
and this is measured by a machine and
the average has to be within a certain
limit
the lamps that are used in uv testing
shine a circle of uv
onto the skin they have to give out the
same amount of uv a consistent amount
over the area of the circle
so you can see there are a lot of tiny
things in the spf test that could
influence the result that weren't
actually specified before
there's also some things that still
aren't standardized and maybe can't be
standardized so for example the person
spreading the sunscreen
they're meant to use a light pressure
but one person's light might not be
another person's light and it's pretty
much impossible for the person to use
the exact same pressure
for every single sample they're
spreading there are a few reference
sunscreens used for spf testing
and the labs use these to see how well
that test was performed for that
particular batch of people
here's the acceptable variation for each
sunscreen you can see that as you get to
higher spfs the accepted variation gets
a lot bigger it's actually a lot harder
to measure a higher spf
with these you can see that the upper
limit is somewhere around double the
lower limit and remember this is
considered good reproducibility
now the in vivo tests are pretty much
the same around the world
but one factor that does change is the
types of volunteers used
in the iso test you're meant to use a
range of different skin types from photo
type 1 to photo type 3.
this is now measured using a machine and
skin color but obviously depending on
the country you're going to get
different volunteers coming in for these
tests
if you look at spf testing data you'll
often see this reflected
so in asian countries you tend to get a
lot more phototype 3
in western countries you get a lot more
phototype 2 the test procedures are
slightly different depending on how
prone to burning you are
and so this could influence the final
results this is particularly a problem
if the tester gets the skin type wrong
and this is one of the things that
machine measurement is meant to help fix
so spf test results from different
countries could be affected by this
difference
along with the issues with the spf test
there might be differences between
different batches of sunscreen
sunscreen manufacturers usually get that
label test on an early version of the
sunscreen
and they might not re-test it with a
proper in vivo test for many years
small changes in the production of the
sunscreen can also affect the spf value
there's usually some testing for
consistent composition
so for example to make sure there's
actually five percent oxybenzone every
time
but again there are lots of other things
in the formula that can change that spf
sunscreens also settle over time so
depending on how fresh the sunscreen is
that can change the spf as well
so with all of these issues with in vivo
spf testing that's why i really think
you do need
two in vivo spf tests to raise
significant doubt over an spf label
claim
and that's what judit says in the inci
decoder blog post as well
if we only have one then it's really
hard to say whether it's just an issue
with inter-lab reproducibility
or if there's actually a problem with
the sunscreen i think when you have two
in vivo spf tests that agree and one
that doesn't
that's when you can confidently say
there probably is a problem somewhere
and the burden of proof switches purito
posted an update saying they paused the
sales of their sunscreen
and because people had complained to
them earlier about getting burned
they had actually sent their sunscreens
off for extra testing
which i think is the right thing to do
there is still the possibility that the
sample sent to the european labs was a
particularly bad batch
or that the sample sent for the original
testing in the korean lab
was a particularly good batch the
samples for the inci decoder test were
also put into a different plastic
container and then sent off for testing
and so there is a possibility there that
the sunscreen reacted with the container
someone did point out that it says
yellow whereas the purito sunscreen is
actually closer to white
it is really subjective what color is
but that could potentially be a sign of
an issue
so are asian sunscreens less trustworthy
since the purito news came out there's
been a lot of talk of not trusting
korean or asian regulation or testing or
brands
and only trusting larger western
manufacturers but sunscreens getting
tested at
spfs that are lower than their labels has
happened a lot of times before
there are a number of consumer advocacy
groups around the world
who retest sunscreens using in vivo
methods and a lot of the time they get
bad results that are lower than the
label
this happens with western brands
including a lot of larger western brands
who put a lot of effort into making
really good sunscreens
it's worth noting that the methods used
in these consumer tests and in the inci
decoder test
aren't quite the same as the label test
the biggest difference is the number of
volunteers
for an spf result that goes on the label
the results have to be consistent over
at least 10 volunteers
in the consumer tests they usually just
test on 5 or 10 people and don't talk
about consistency
in one of the inci decoder tests they
only use five results
and in both tests they weren't
consistent enough to be used on
an spf
label
but these tests are in vivo and they
largely use the same procedures
so i think that doesn't affect their
ability to raise doubt over an spf label
claim
so in the u.s consumer reports have
found that a neutrogena sunscreen and a
la roche-posay sunscreen
both tested at less than half their
labeled spfs the neutrogena one was
labeled at spf 70 but was tested at spf
30-39
this la roche-posay one was labeled spf
60 but tested at between 10 and 19.
in 2016 consumer reports found that 23
out of the 60 sunscreens they tested
tested at less than half their labeled
spf in october this year the hong kong
consumer council found that 25 out of 30
sunscreens they tested
had less than their spf label and some
of the ones that failed include really
large reputable sunscreen brands so
Estée Lauder, iPSA, Anessa, Shiseido, Curél
Sofina, Laneige, Dermacept and Bio-Essence
one thing that could be contributing to
why it looks like there's a higher fail
rate for asian sunscreens
is that the consumer tests were
conducted in an australian lab
so that ethnicity difference could be an
issue the worst performing sunscreen was
one from fancl which is a japanese
brand
it was labeled spf 50 plus but it tested
out spf 14.3
and the brand claims that the original
label claim was supported by
two different tests from two different
labs in two different countries one from
the us and one from china
i would say that as a brand the best way
of checking that your spf rating was
valid
is to send it to two different labs into
different countries but even though they
did that there was still that
discrepancy with the consumer test
so in this whole purito conversation
some people have recommended that
australian sunscreens are the way to go
now i am australian and i'm very proud
of how my small country is going in
terms of sunscreen regulation
and sunscreen development and skin
cancer research but this still isn't
error proof
in late 2015 choice magazine tested six
spf 50 plus sunscreens that were
available in australia
and they found that only two of the
sunscreens in the consumer tests
actually met the label claim so this is
not only an issue that you see in korean
sunscreens or asian sunscreens
the fact that this happened with
neutrogena and la roche-posay
two western brands that i consider to be
two of the most trustworthy brands in
sun protection
they always go above and beyond to
develop high protection sunscreens
i think isn't a sign that these brands
can't be trusted or that any sunscreen
that tests below the label claim must be
lying
it's a reflection of issues with spf
testing and with batch variations
and in my opinion a reflection of the
robustness of some sunscreens so
in other words how consistently they
perform over time in different
conditions
which isn't really captured by the
current spf testing
on top of this there's the fact that at
the end of the day you are still relying
on people to do the right thing
the biggest sunscreen labeling scandal
that's ever happened is with ama
labs this is a us-based sunscreen
testing lab
and they're one of the biggest ones
according to the indictment the lab
committed fraud over 30 years between
1987 and 2017.
allegedly they conducted spf testing on
far fewer people than they said they did
and they pocketed the extra difference
and then sent in fraudulent results
one of the sunscreen brands that got
caught in this ama labs mess
was sunsense i consider them to be one
of the best sunscreen brands in
australia they publish a lot of
peer-reviewed research they collaborate
with dermatologists all the time
and in consumer tests sunsense sunscreens
have fallen short
this also happened with another really
reputable brand which was new zealand's
cancer society
so again it happens to brands that are
super trustworthy by any measure
so these issues can apply to the purito
test or the inci decoder test
were they both really the purito
sunscreen did inci decoder accidentally
get a fake tube
did someone somewhere along the line
accidentally use the wrong sunscreen
like ama labs allegedly did someone just
completely make up the numbers
i don't know if this is the case but
it's really hard to be sure without any
extra testing
i don't think there's necessarily any
wrongdoing on anyone's part here there
are explanations that don't involve that
my gut feeling is that it's more likely
than not there is some sort of issue
with the sunscreen
and that can range from whether it's
just really not that robust
or someone has straight up being
fraudulent it's impossible to say where
in the process this has happened and
whose fault it is
from the actions that purito have taken
so the fact that they're releasing lots
of information that they're not legally
required to
i am leaning towards there not being any
intentional wrongdoing on their part
for now i'm personally treating the
purito sunscreen as an everyday
sunscreen that doesn't necessarily
have higher than spf 19.
[Music]
if you're new to all this info i know it
can feel really daunting and you might
be wondering how you can trust any
sunscreen brand ever again
but please don't freak out keep in mind
that there are people out there who have
known all these issues with spf testing
and all of these consumer reports for
years and years and they still use
sunscreen
so at the end of the day with all of
this uncertainty how can we be
somewhat sure that we're picking a
sunscreen with good protection
unless you are testing every tube of
sunscreen that you use on a panel of
people
there is no way to be absolutely sure
that the rating you're getting is the
rating on the label
just like you can never guarantee that
your frozen berries don't have hepatitis
a
and that your car doesn't have lethal
airbags but if you do want to go beyond
the spf label
here are some of the things that point
towards a more reliable sunscreen
despite all of this uncertainty
an spf that's validated by an
international consumer research and
testing report
a water resistance rating a higher total
concentration of sunscreen filters
the presence of known spf boosters and
film formers in the inactive
ingredients
a thicker product consistency so sticks
are better than lotions
getting a sunscreen from a country that
regulates sunscreens as drugs or
functional cosmetics
a brand that is large enough to attract
the attention of regulatory authorities
good storage conditions and purchasing
from a reputable retailer
there are a lot of things in my
suggested list that aren't compatible
with each other or aren't compatible
with your life so there's going to have
to be some compromise
sunscreen sticks tend to give the best
protection provided you apply enough
but consumer groups tend not to test
sticks and sticks tend to
be really uncomfortable and clog your
pores us sunscreens have been tested the
most by consumer groups but
us sunscreens have lots of problems they
use the older filters that aren't as
stable in the sun
they have a lower requirement for broad
spectrum and the filters tend to be more
allergenic and irritating
european sunscreens tend to use the
newer filters they tend to use higher
concentrations and have thicker textures
but they're not regulated as drugs
they're regulated as regular cosmetics
australia has the newerl filters a good
broad spectrum rating system
and sunscreens are regulated as drugs
but if you insist on having validated
spfs then
you're kind of out of luck because
there's only ever been six that have
been tested
and only two of them passed and this was
back in 2015 both of these sunscreens
have been relisted since so their
formulations might have changed
if you have to buy a sunscreen from
overseas then you can't be certain about
the conditions that it goes under on its
way to you
it's always best to go for a sunscreen
that's suited for what you're doing so
for example if you're just staying
mostly indoors then you probably don't
need to care about as many of this
criteria
if you're spending a long time in the
sun then you want something that ticks
off more boxes
if you're using a sunscreen and you're
getting burnt or your pigment is getting
darker then it's a sign that the
sunscreen isn't working for you
whether it's mislabeled or not water
resistant enough or you're just not
managing to apply enough
whatever the reason is it's time to
switch to a different sunscreen
and it's important to remember that
sunscreen is not a suit of armor and
it's only one part of sun protection and
not the most important part
wearing a hat wearing upf clothing
seeking shade and avoiding the sun in
the middle of the day are super
important
one thing i find helpful when i'm
worrying too much about sunscreen
whether it's whether my sunscreen is
reliable or if i'm using it correctly
is remembering the results of the nambour
study this was the biggest study ever on
sunscreen involving 600 people
one group put sunscreen on every day on
their head neck hands and arms
and the other group just used sunscreen
when they felt like it after four and a
half years the skin of daily sunscreen
users had no detectable increase in
aging
and they were 24% less likely to show
increased signs of aging
invasive melanomas were almost four
times less common in daily sunscreen
users
these results are even more incredible
because the study was done in the 90s
using a 90s sunscreen
it had spf 16 8% octinoxate and 2%
oxybenzone and this was done in
queensland australia where there is a
lot of uv
so even if your sunscreen application
isn't optimal you are still getting a
lot of protection
i hope you enjoyed this deep dive into
some of the issues around spf
this only really just skims the surface
but hopefully the complexity of the
whole situation makes a lot more sense
now
leave me any questions you have if you
liked it drop a like and a subscribe
you can follow me on instagram loudmouth
and beauty science to check out my blog
for more nerdy beauty
content see you next time to nerd out
more